people had been waiting for eight hours
trying to me and then didn't because
even in eight hours you can only get to
about a hundred or 200 people when
thousands and thousands are trying to me
and even now now that I have ten million
subscribers it would be even worse of
people trying me so I'm pretty sure this
was supposed to turn into a white okay
me me shut up me just me come on
Oh Bob is himself but I really love this
expression down in the corner couch
isn't as much a thing as it is today and
I really wish it was because couch
cooperative he's one of the favorite
things that I had as a child to look up
okay I'm not gonna mop this bubble I'm
gonna go home and then Bob and Wade and
then have a good time back there but if
anyone has any recommendations of
British and getting British and how to
get that I will do a video trying
British people want to see that the may
be all this endless conquest isn't
filling up the empty void in my figure
out how to get the goggles off of them
because how am I supposed to be able to
do this surgery if I can't get the
goggles off so I'm guessing I need to
come I need to just inform you that I
mean a lot of girls aliens cats tons of
girls all over the place I don't do
drugs
I don't even anymore so I am as square
as could be okay back up a little bit
there I don't need to get that closer
you might do something bad I'm assuming
the D stands for hello she even though
it's in the real world that never would
I can still picture weed blower sleeping
self over and over and eating a very old
recommend always
Oh Oh actually no I have never tried
British and as always that will do in
the next video
[Music]